JENNA TAYLOR: We
are obviously super
excited to have chef J.
Kenji Lopez-Alt with us.
[APPLAUSE]
Many of you know chef
Lopez-Alt as the managing
culinary director
of Serious Eats,
or maybe from his
James Beard award
nominated column "The Food Lab."
He's an MIT grad.
He's restaurant trained chef.
He is a husband of a Googler.
Good job, us.
And now he is the author of the
new book "The Food Lab Better
Home Cooking Through Science."
So Chef-- oh, sorry, Kenji,
my close personal friend.
Welcome to Google.
J. KENJI LOPEZ ALT: Everybody's
lose personal friend.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
It's really amazing to be here.
Everybody here is
way smarter than me,
which is really
intimidating, but hopefully I
think I'm better at
cooking eggs than everybody
here so that makes me
feel a little better.
JENNA TAYLOR: And you
also have your wife--
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: And
my wife is here, yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: You
guys are combined.
J. KENJI LOPEZ
ALT: Moral support.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Super smart.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Yes, she's here.
And she pays my
health insurance, too.
Or Google pays my
health insurance.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNA TAYLOR: You're welcome.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Although, I just
realized if it weren't
for my health insurance,
I would never have
gone to my doctor
and I would not have found out
that I have high cholesterol.
So basically everybody
here is responsible for
my high cholesterol, I think.
Anyhow, my wife told
me that-- last night I
did an event also the San
Francisco cooking school.
And she told me that the big
mistake I made last night
was not telling everybody
at the very beginning what
I'm going to be doing for
the rest of the time, rest
of presentation.
So I'm going to tell everybody
what I'm going to be doing,
which is cooking eggs.
And showing you all the
different things that eggs
can do, not all the
different things,
but some of the different
things that eggs can do,
because they're amazing.
They come out of
chickens or other birds.
These ones come out of chickens.
Most eggs that we eat
come out of chickens.
And you can eat
them, but they also
have these really
unique chemical
and physical properties that
help us sort of manipulate
other foods into neat things.
So what we're going
to do today is
I'm going to show you
unique method of poaching
eggs that will make
you the star of brunch.
And then I'm going
to show you how
you can use eggs to make a
really foolproof mayonnaise
and a really fool proof
hollandaise, which will also
make you a star of brunch.
And then we're going to talk
a little bit about salads,
because well the
poached eggs we have
are going to go into a
brussels sprouts salad
that the kitchen is
preparing, which I think
everybody can eat afterwards.
Is that right?
JENNA TAYLOR: Absolutely.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
I think, so, yeah.
So we're going to
talk a little bit
about salads and vinaigrettes.
So eggs, then
emulsions with eggs,
and then emulsions without eggs.
And that's what we're doing.
So the first one is poached egg.
So I don't know how
many of you have
tried poaching an egg before.
It's not extremely easy,
even in a restaurant.
I used to work in a
restaurant in Boston,
where I was in
charge of breakfast.
And so there were
days of the week when
I had to go in at
6:00 in the morning
and start poaching eggs
for breakfast service.
And I would say for my
first month there, at least,
I probably had like
a 30% success rate.
We ended up eating a lot
eggs for family meal,
because the eggs
break, they fall apart,
the egg whites turn
all wispy in there,
and it's really,
really difficult
to get a nice
perfectly poached eggs.
And you'll find that
there's people that tell you
many different ways to do it.
What I was taught was that you
take the pot, you have water,
you salt the water.
Actually I am going to salt
the water for a little bit.
You salt the water.
And then I was told to
put vinegar in the water,
because it helps the egg white
settle a little bit faster.
And then I was taught to stir
a vortex into it like this,
break my eggs into a
separate little container,
and then pour it gently into
the middle of that vortex.
And supposedly the
vortex is supposed
to help you maintain like a
nice sort of for torpedo shape.
The idea is that as it
falls into that vortex,
it swirls around like this.
And because the egg
white and the egg yolk
have a different density it
kind of leaves like a trail,
kind of like a
comet going around.
So the yolk will
go in the front,
the white will trail behind it.
And that's supposed to give
it a really nice shape.
But in reality, what
happens is you end up
breaking half your eggs.
They swirl around
in there and then
you end up with egg drop soup
and you have to start over.
And it's not fun.
It's not fun.
Any line cookers who had
to poach a lot of eggs
can tell you it's not easy.
So what we're actually
going to do instead
is we're going to take our eggs.
These are eggs.
I already showed
you eggs before,
didn't I. Now the one
thing you want to do,
you want to make
sure when you're
poaching eggs is that your
eggs are really, really fresh.
You want them to be like
within a couple weeks of having
coming out of the chicken.
If you can get them like the
day of, that's even better.
But what happens is--
let me break open an egg
and show you something here.
So when you break open an
egg, immediately what you see
is obviously two things.
There is the white and the yolk.
But actually there are really
three phases in an egg.
So there is the yolk, which
is inside its own little sack,
its own membrane.
There's the white, which is
also in its own membrane.
But then there's also
all this loose white,
which is not within
that same little sack
as the main part of the white.
And that excess loose
weight, that's the problem.
That's what makes your
eggs fall apart in there.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's what gets
all wispy and flying around.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Exactly.
That's what gets all wispy.
And the thing is the
older your egg is,
the weaker the membranes
in there are going to be.
So the higher the
chance it's going
to be that you're going to
break your eggs when it falls
into the water or that there's
going to be too much of that
lose white.
So what you really
want to do when
you're going to poach eggs is
find the freshest eggs you can.
There's a couple ways you
can tell how fresh an egg is.
The first one is
just look at the box,
because they all
have a sell by date.
The sell by date by law has
to be within 30 days at a time
that the egg was
packed into the carton.
But it can be anywhere
within that 30 day range.
So the real number
you're looking for
is what's called the
Julian date and it'll
be a three digit number on the
carton right next to the sell
by date.
And that three digit
number is the day
that the eggs were packed on.
It goes one to 365, obviously.
And as I just
found out, when you
search for what is the
252nd day of the year,
Google doesn't immediately
give you an answer.
You have to go to a chart.
So maybe somebody
can get on that.
[LAUGHTER]
If you really have
no idea, another way
you can tell your eggs is
by you get a cup of water
and-- I don't know how many of
you've really closely looked
at a hard boiled egg.
I'm sure most of you here
have eaten a hard boiled egg.
When you peel a hard boiled
egg along this fat end,
you sometimes see
this little divot,
this little bubble in there.
And that bubble is
in there naturally
and it always
forms on this side.
As the egg gets
older and older--
the shell is slightly porous so
it will actually lose moisture
and particularly in the
US, because eggs in the US
are washed before packing.
So when it comes
out of the chicken,
there's this kind of
natural waxy cuticle on it
that is also a weather barrier.
So European eggs--
you might notice
if you go to Europe, eggs are
stored at room temperature,
whereas in the US they're
stored in the fridge.
And the reason for that
is because in Europe they
don't wash the eggs after
they come out of the chicken
so that waxy cuticle is intact.
So it actually helps protect
the egg from losing moisture.
It also helps protect it
from bacterial infection
from the outside.
In the US, they wash them first.
So they start out
cleaner, but they're also
more vulnerable to other things.
But anyhow, what happens
is the moisture comes out.
And as the moisture comes
out, that bubble in there
gets bigger and bigger.
So a very, very
fresh egg-- and we're
going to see how
fresh this one is.
So there you go.
A very, very fresh egg will
lay on its side like that.
As the egg gets older
and older, you're
going to see that it's
going to start floating.
Well, initially it'll start
standing up with its fat end
up.
And eventually if it
gets really, really old
it's going to actually float.
And at that point,
you don't really
want to do anything other
than throw it at people.
So these are fresh
eggs, which is good.
But as I pointed out,
even with a very fresh egg
there's still a good amount
of that really liquidy white
and that's your enemy.
So the secret to getting rid of
that is you just use a strainer
and you just pour your
egg right in there
and you can see all the
liquid white drips off.
And that's all stuff
that would have
gone into your pot of water
and clotted it up and made
those little wispy things.
And once you have your basically
clean, tight white and tight
yolk in there, you
can very gently
lower it into the water like
this and just kind roll it out.
And is there a way for
people to see in there?
I don't know if there's a way
for people to see in there.
But it looks awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
And then once it's in there you
give it a couple little stirs.
One thing you don't
want to happen
is for that egg to
stick on the bottom,
because even though
you're in a pot of water
the metal on the
bottom of the pot
is going to conduct
heat into the egg
obviously faster
than the water is.
So you want to make sure
this is moving a little bit.
And this is just going to take
about maybe 30, 45 seconds
to a minute.
And once you have
an egg in there
you can do any number of them.
It gets pretty easy once
you get going at this.
Egg whites come out
and egg goes in.
And I think that first one is
nearly done already, actually.
So I'm just going to
grab a slotted spoon here
and fish it out.
And there.
So you can see it's like
a perfectly tight white.
There's nothing-- no like
wispy bits coming out.
This is a picture
perfect poached egg,
that's what you're looking for.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Now even though that's
really easy and pretty much
foolproof, but actually I
use the word fool resistant.
There's a lot of
engineers in here
and I'm sure that you
know-- every time you
make something foolproof then
a bigger fool comes around.
So it's a fool resistant method.
I'm sure someone's
going to mess it up.
But even though it's
pretty foolproof,
it's still a bit of
effort to do while you're
trying to-- say you have six or
eight friends over for brunch,
and you want to make eggs
benedict for everybody;
that's like a dozen
eggs you have to poach.
So that's going to tie you up
in the kitchen for a while.
So a much easier way to do it is
to actually poach your eggs off
the day before or
even up to few days
before, and then transfer them
to a bowl of water, cold water.
You can take this bowl
and put it in your fridge
and leave it for three days.
And the eggs are just going
to stay perfectly poached,
they're not going to
cook anymore, obviously.
And they're not going
to lose any quality.
And the day that you
want to serve your brunch
you take your poached egg
and just put it right back
in the hot water for
about 15, 30 seconds
and then you have a
nice hot poached egg.
And you do 12 of them,
dump them in a pot of water
and that's like
brunch for everyone
within a couple minutes,
which is really nice, I think.
JENNA TAYLOR: My life
just changed forever.
Unbelievable.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: All right.
So this is poached eggs.
And it's a lot of
poached eggs, actually.
All right, so now we're
going to talk about-- now
I'm going to dump
this out, actually.
And then I'm going to get some
butter melting, because we're
going to make some hollandaise
to go with that poached egg.
This is a lot of butter.
It's a pound, I think.
Pound of unsalted butter.
I don't know how
these things work.
It says 1,000.
What does 1,000 mean?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
I want 1,001.
No, OK.
1,000 is good.
Maybe it's watts?
I don't know.
All right.
So one of the other
cool properties of eggs,
in particularly egg yolks is
that they contain lecithin.
Lecithin is an emulsifier.
And I don't know how many of
you are familiar with what
an emulsion is, but an
emulsion is essentially
when you take two liquids
that are immiscible
and force them to mix.
In cooking it's almost
always a water-based liquid
and a fat-based liquid.
So like a traditional
vinaigrette,
which we'll make it a bit.
A butter is an emulsion.
There's water in there, there's
about-- off the top of my head
if I'm right, I think it's like
15% water and about 80% fat
and a few other
percents of protein.
And then what we're
going to make now
is mayonnaise and hollandaise
which are both emulsions.
They're both fat
in water emotions.
Now in order to get
things to emulsify,
what you need is a lot of
mechanical stirring first
of all, and then
also an emulsifier.
An emulsifier is
any sort of agent
that has one hydrophobic
end and one hydrophilic end.
So essentially what
you're doing is
you're taking your
tiny droplets of fat
or your tiny droplets
of water surrounding it
on all sides with emulsifiers.
So if you think of them as like
little sperm going into an egg,
they got their heads
jammed in there.
So if you have a fat molecule
all the hydrophilic ends
are jammed into the
fat molecule, which
leaves the exterior hydrophobic,
which makes it-- or did
I reverse that?
I reversed it.
Anyhow, you know what I mean.
So it makes it so that
those fat molecules can then
be evenly distributed in water.
The way you traditionally
would make a mayonnaise
is kind of a pain in the butt.
I'm going to do it right
here and it's probably
going to fail because I
haven't done it in so long.
So what you do is you take
your egg, just the yolk.
We're going to do a
little bit of lemon juice.
A little bit of water--
I think this is water.
We'll see.
And then a little
bit of mustard.
Mustard also is a
pretty good emulsifier.
For this one let's do a
little bit of garlic, too.
I like to use a
microplane for my garlic,
although some people, I think,
Anthony Bourdain and Alton
Brown hate garlic presses.
I don't mind garlic presses,
I think they work fine.
But I generally use a
microplane, because I have it
around.
All right, so to make a classic
mayonnaise you start out
with an egg yolk,
mustard, lemon juice.
And the real trick to
making a mayonnaise
is that you have to add the
oil really, really slowly.
Oh, actually-- someone
in the kitchen there,
can someone grab me like
a court of canola oil?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Yes.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Yeah.
We'll start this
one with olive oil
just because I have it here.
The trick is to add the
oil really, really slowly.
And the idea there is
that by adding it slowly
you're able to break down the
droplets into very, very, very
fine droplets.
And that's what you need
because if they're too large
they end up
attracting each other.
And I like to
think of it sort of
as like a high school dance,
where the water's the boys
and the oil's the girls, or
maybe the other way around.
Oh, thank you.
And then once the boys start
forming a little clump,
all the other boys
are like, oh there's
boys I'm going to go over there.
And then they glom onto
them and then you end up
with people on separate
sides of the dance floor
and that's not what you want.
You really want to maybe
give them a little alcohol.
Lecithin is like the the
alcohol of the mayonnaise party.
Give them a little
bit of alcohol,
help them mixed together,
and they keep it separated.
Very little bit at a time.
Whisk very furiously.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Cardiovascular for the day.
Maybe you didn't want
to do arms at the gym.
You just make mayonnaise.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
OK, I'm not going
to bore you making
this fully, but you
can see it starts to form
this nice creamy sauce.
And as you add more
and more oil it's
actually going to get
thicker and thicker.
And that's one of the
interesting properties
of an emulsion is
that an emulsion
is thicker than either of the
two ingredients on their own,
always.
And that's just
because of the way
they rub together when they're
trying to move around in there.
So that's how you make
a traditional mayo.
It's definitely not foolproof
and it takes some practice.
So what we're going to do
is make a foolproof mayo.
Fool resistant.
JENNA TAYLOR: Fool resistant.
J. KENJI LOPEZ ALT:
Fool resistant mayo.
Actually, could we get
even a little more oil?
One more little bottle?
Because this is a
pretty big container.
JENNA TAYLOR: You can
have all of our oil.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: All right.
JENNA TAYLOR: We'll
line it up for you.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: So I'm
going to put an egg in there.
This time I'm
actually just going
to leave the white in there.
You can leave the
white in if you want.
And I'll just leave out the
water, because egg whites are
mostly water anyway.
Egg white, lemon juice,
some of my garlic.
Thank you.
Oh, there you go.
JENNA TAYLOR: Bam.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Value size.
This is the Costco container.
Mustard.
All right.
And now remember I told you that
you have to add the oil really
slowly to mayonnaise.
JENNA TAYLOR: Uh-oh,
what's happening?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: So
what we're going to do
is we're just going
to dump this in.
All the way.
And that's what happens if you
add oil too fast to mayonnaise.
Obviously, it doesn't mix.
But if you have
one of these guys,
an immersion
blender-- So the idea
here is that if you can see it
all of the water-based liquid
is at the bottom.
All the oils at the top.
And now this guy is
going to create a vortex
and that vortex is going to
very slowly draw the oil down
into the water.
So by sticking this all
the way to the bottom
and turning it on, we're
going to basically do
what we were doing before
very, very slowly add the oil
phase to the water phase.
And unless I've suddenly
become a bigger fool,
this will hopefully work.
I think it will work.
Ready?
It is working.
JENNA TAYLOR: Seriously,
where have you
been all of my culinary life?
Look at this.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
And then season it
with a little salt, pepper.
And that's mayonnaise, see?
I don't know how this works.
AUDIENCE: What exactly
was that device again?
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
an immersion blender.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: This
is an immersion blender.
Yeah, yeah, you can
get them for about,
I mean I think like
Cuisinart makes them--
JENNA TAYLOR: $30.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: $35.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Target, anywhere.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: This will
be way better than anything
you ever get out of a jar.
Yeah, tastes like mayonnaise.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: How long would
that keep in the fridge?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: I put
the garlic and lemon juice
in there.
So those are the things that
are really going to kill it.
If you did it with
like no garlic
and did it with just like
vinegar instead lemon juice
it will last weeks.
I mean as long as as
commercial mayo did basically.
With the garlic and
lemon juice you'll
start to taste maybe some
funny off flavors after one
and a half weeks or so.
AUDIENCE: So the lemon juice
is for flavor more than
for the acid?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Yeah, well, for both.
It's for flavor, it's for
acidity, I mean, brightness,
because you can make mayonnaise
with just water and oil,
but it tastes greasy and gross.
Yeah.
You want acid in there to
really give a brightness.
I usually put quite a
bit of acid in there.
This one is less acid
than I normally would.
The one thing you want to
make sure, a lot of people
make mayonnaise with olive oil.
The one thing you
don't want to do
is do exactly what I just
did with just pure olive oil.
And the reason is that
olive oil, it'll oxidize.
If it comes into contact
with them too much air
and if you mix it
too violently, it
has aromatic compounds in
there that sheer and oxidize.
And it'll developed some
really bitter flavors.
So I don't know if
you've ever tried
putting olive oil in the blender
and tasting it afterwards.
Just that action, just like
putting it in a blender
and blending it for 10 seconds
it makes it taste disgusting.
So if you want to make a really
like olive oily mayonnaise,
start with about half
the amount of canola oil
or a vegetable oil, some
kind of neutral oil.
Start with about
half the amount,
get your mayonnaise stable,
then transfer it to a bowl,
add your olive oil
and whisk it in.
And once you have a
really nice stable base,
it's actually pretty easy to
add, whisk more oil into it,
it's not going to break.
So there we have mayonnaise.
Now the question is how
do you make hollandaise.
And hollandaise-- once you
know how to make mayonnaise,
hollandaise is like--
I mean it's basically
the exact same thing.
The only difference is
that instead of oil you're
using butter, another fat.
Hollandaise is one
of these sauces
that is, again, like the bane
of a lot of brunch cooks'
existence.
It has all the difficulties
of a mayonnaise
getting proper emulsion
to form, all of that.
Plus it's also very
temperature sensitive.
If it gets too cool-- butter is
a highly saturated fat, which
means that-- I
don't know if you're
familiar with the shape
of a fat molecule,
but it basically
looks like an e.
Like it's got one-- what is it?
Three fatty acids
and a glyceride.
It's got a glyceride chain and
fatty acids sticking out of it.
Those fatty acids they
have kinks in them
based on how saturated or
unsaturated that the fat is.
So when it's fully
saturated that
means that every single
location on that fatty acid
has a carbon.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Hydrogen?
Hydrogen. Yes, thank you.
It has hydrogen on it, which
makes the legs straight.
When it is missing
some of those hydrogens
those legs end up kinking.
So when you have a non
fully saturated fat
it has kinked legs,
which means that it
doesn't stack very easily.
The molecules don't
pack very tightly.
So highly saturated
fats like butter--
tend to come from animals--
butter, beef fat, pork fat,
duck fat-- you'll find that
because they stack so nicely
they are solids at
room temperature.
So obviously you can't make
mayonnaise out of a solid.
So hollandaise is difficult,
because if the butter fat gets
too cool, it becomes a solid.
It breaks out of its emulsion.
But if it gets too hot, you
end up cooking the egg yolks.
So it's really this
balancing game,
but when you use this method it
solves a lot of those problems,
again.
Can I grab some more eggs, too?
Just a couple more.
Probably won't
actually need them.
We'll see.
With the hollandaise, it's a
little bit more of an egg sauce
than a mayonnaise is.
So I like to use about 4 to
6 eggs per pound of butter.
Egg yolks again.
One, two, three.
Anybody know any good
jokes about eggs?
AUDIENCE: What do you
do with your egg whites?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: You
make souffles out of them
or make meringues out of them.
Or yeah, any one
of those things.
JENNA TAYLOR: Once
you separate them--
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Or
make egg white omelettes.
JENNA TAYLOR: How long
can you keep them?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Oh, a long time.
And you can freeze them.
Put them in a
container, freeze them.
They freeze really well.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you don't
like to blend olive oil,
does that mean you don't like
to make pesto in a blender?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Well, so a you
don't want to make
pesto in the blender,
because it's not the
best way to get flavor.
You want to make pesto it
in a mortar and pestle.
You rupture a lot more.
So a blender is
actually too violent.
And it's too sharp.
So it'll separate plant
cells at their walls.
So you actually don't extract
as much flavor-- thank you--
when you blend like basil.
You don't extract as
much flavor out of it
as you do when you really grind
it in a mortar and pestle.
When you make your
pesto, you want
to get a nice granite
mortar and pestle.
And this is one of
the rare cases where
the really old
fashioned way actually
is the best way to do it.
You want a grand and
mortar pestle, salt,
which is also an
abrasive and will
help you break it down more.
And that'll make
it better pesto.
But to answer your
initial question,
if you are going to make your
pesto in a blender and a food
processor, it's
actually relatively OK
to put olive oil in there.
And it's because all
that solid matter really
protects the olive
oil from getting
sheared by the blades spinning.
So you don't notice the effect
nearly as much when you have
a lot of solid matter in there.
This is always my favorite part.
OK.
So again, I'm a little
nervous at this point.
When you do things live
they never work the way
they're supposed to.
We'll see.
JENNA TAYLOR: Just
launch and iterate.
We just launch and iterate.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: All right.
Same thing here-- eggs,
little lemon juice,
then we got hot butter here.
I'm using a thermometer
that I borrowed from someone
over there.
Let's see.
Right now it's like
close to 200 degrees,
which is maybe a little hotter
than I want it but will do.
Hopefully won't scramble
the eggs before we're done.
What did I do with that blender?
So the process is pretty
much exactly the same.
The only difference
is in this case
you can't pour
the butter on top,
because if all that hot
butter sits on top of eggs
it ends up cooking the eggs.
So this one you do
have to double fist it
and do one hand
here, one hand here.
OK, we got this going.
Ready?
Hold your breath.
And as the butter goes in
it's going to emulsify,
but it's also going
to slightly cook
those egg yolks,
which is kind of what
you want in a hollandaise.
It'll make it really
nice and thick.
And what you want
to do is pour off
all of this sort of
clear yellow fat.
And I don't know if you
can see into this pot,
but there's a bunch of white
liquid left at the bottom.
And that's basically
the water phase
of the butter that's
left down there along
with some dissolved proteins.
Really all you want
is the fat in here.
If it ends up too thick you can
add some of that water phase.
But this one looks
like it's pretty good.
And we'll season
it with salt again.
Some people like the
cayenne in there.
I'll do just some salt. That
tastes like hollandaise.
And wait, let me show
you how cool this looks.
Let's get some of
those eggs from before.
Let me grab a paper towel.
So these eggs are a little cold,
but imagine that they're warm.
You don't have to
imagine, because you can't
taste-- these eggs are warm.
JENNA TAYLOR: Steamy.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Perfect
serving temperature.
JENNA TAYLOR: How
long in advance
can you make hollandaise?
How long will it stay?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: That one
you do have to kind of make--
JENNA TAYLOR: Kind
of a la minute, yeah.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: A la minute.
Yeah.
So if you have a really nice
heavy, heavy pot-- even this
will do with a
tightly sealing lid.
You can put a lid
on it and let it
keep under it's own-- put in a
kind of warm spot on your oven.
And it'll last.
You might find that depending
on if it gets slightly too warm,
it's going to start to thicken.
And egg proteins even at
the same temperature, like
say you're holding
them at 160 degrees,
even if you're holding
at a 160 degrees,
over time they'll
thicken more and more.
So if you hold your
hollandaise for 45 minutes,
it's going to get pretty thick.
If you hold it for two hours
it'll probably get solid.
It's rescuable.
You can always whisk in a little
bit more liquid to save it,
but it's never going to be
quite the same as when you first
made it.
So it is one of
the things I would
recommend making a la minute.
I broke that egg.
I spent too long talking to you.
All right.
So I poached the egg
perfectly and then
I broke it when I
started plating.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Nobody saw, but me.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
And this is what
is going to get your friends
to love you on brunch.
There and that's
hollandaise for you.
What time are we at now?
Do I have time to
go into another--
JENNA TAYLOR: Five minutes.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: I
have five minutes left.
And does that include
questions and answers?
AUDIENCE: Additional
questions and answers after.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
After this, OK.
All right.
We're going to do
one last thing.
JENNA TAYLOR: But we did
start five minutes late
so do we get an
extra five minutes?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: We're good.
So I'm not going to bother
cooking the brussels sprouts,
because that's going
to take too long.
But we are going to talk
quickly about vinaigrettes.
So a vinaigrette is also an
emulsion, also a oil and water
emulsion.
Generally, the
water-based element
is an acid, like lemon
juice or vinegar.
Can I grab a-- I need
some more lemons, too.
AUDIENCE: More lemons.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: I
used up all my lemons.
So again, making a vinaigrette
the traditional way
is actually very similar
to making a mayonnaise.
You start with your acid, maybe
a little bit of mustard, maybe
a shallot or two in a bowl.
Start whisking it and then
slowly drizzle in your oil.
And you end up with an emulsion.
Because there's no
lecithin in there
the emulsion is not quite as
strong as it is in mayonnaise.
And that's why mayonnaise
is so thick and gloppy,
whereas a vinaigrette
is loose and creamy.
So people sometimes ask why do
you need to make a vinaigrette?
Why can't I just put oil
and vinegar on my salad?
They're like, they do it
the Italian restaurants,
they come around with like the
little caddy of-- thank you.
Oil and vinegar.
And the question is why can't
you just put them on separately
and toss it all together.
And so I want to
quickly demonstrate
what happens if you do that.
So I have this bowl here.
This first bowl we're going
to put some salad greens.
And imagine that I'm
measuring everything
here really precisely.
We're going to put
some salad greens
and we're going to
do just oil in it,
about a tablespoon of oil.
OK?
I'm going to toss
this together and then
I'm going to put them
in this strainer.
And I grab a clean
bowl, excuse me.
Can you still hear me from here?
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
like "Top Chef."
We're going to make him run all
over the place, set the timer--
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: All right.
So we're going to put
it in a clean bowl
and we're going to watch
what happens there.
Then the next one,
we're going to take
about the same amount
of greens and we're
going to add some lemon juice
to them; also about a tablespoon
or so of lemon juice.
Toss them and then we're
going to put them here.
And then the final bowl we're
going to make a vinaigrette.
I'm going to do it in a jar
instead of the traditional way.
No, I'll do it the
traditional way.
So lemon juice, a little
mustard, and my whisk
went-- I wonder
where my whisk went.
I'll grab another one.
JENNA TAYLOR: Run, run!
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
I don't know.
Are those all set up
for someone after?
I don't know if I'm
stealing someone else's--
JENNA TAYLOR: You're welcome
to use any of our tools.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: So basically
same as the mayonnaise.
We're going to drizzle in
some olive oil pretty slowly.
For a vinaigrette I usually
like to go by the three to one
ratio of oil to
water-based liquid.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Say again?
JENNA TAYLOR: What's
the emulsifier?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Mustard.
Mustard.
Yeah.
But mustard is not as
strong as lecithin,
which is why it doesn't really
hold the emulsion as well.
You know, and even
without an emulsifier,
it's possible to get like a
relatively loose emulsion.
But it'll eventually separate.
But this one you see,
it's pretty creamy.
So this one we're going to
also throw some salad greens.
I'm adding a couple
tablespoons of this.
Toss them all together.
And where did I put
that clean bowl?
Did I lose my last clean bowl?
Let's go with this bowl.
OK.
There we go.
And hopefully this is
actually going to work out
the way it's supposed to.
Sometimes it does.
All right, so this
one is tossed with oil
and you can see like basically
nothing drips into the bowl.
And that's because leaves
have this kind of natural waxy
coating on them so that
when they're out in the rain
the rain just rolls off of them
instead of soaking into them.
So oil actually binds
really well to salad greens
and to leaves of all kinds.
And actually if you've seen your
salad green start to go limp,
it's the oil that's doing it.
It's not the acid.
It's not the water.
It's the oil.
So you can see like here it's
already starting to go limp
and that's because the oil
is soaking into the leaves
and saturating the cells.
So no dripping from oil.
So it's good because the
oil sticks to the leaves
and that's where you
want it, because that's
where you get the
flavor, but it's bad
because it ruins your greens.
Now we go to the
one with the acid
and this is the one
that I hope worked.
And imagine that the bowl has
a lot of stuff down there.
JENNA TAYLOR: Tons,
tons of stuff.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: If we had
it sit a little bit longer
you would have probably seen it.
Or if this thing had
bigger holes in it.
Oh, yeah, it's all pulling
at the bottom of the thing.
Anyhow, your acid basically
it just runs off the leaves,
it doesn't really stick to them.
And that's bad, because you
need that bright acidity to make
your salad taste good.
So the point of a vinaigrette
is that you get your acid in oil
to play nicely together.
And then here again no drippage.
It coats the leaves nicely,
but now coating the leaves
is oil plus acid.
So you get the flavor
from the olive oil,
you also get the
flavor from the acid.
The leaves are protected
from the effects of the oil,
because of that
water-based element.
And so that's the reason why
you want to actually form
a really nice tight vinaigrette
and not just haphazardly throw
things on your salad.
And it's also why
it doesn't work
to just kind of add extra
vinegar at the table
or whatever.
You need to really
make a nice vinaigrette
if you want a nice salad.
Actually I had a really nice
salad out here for lunch.
I'm pretty sure
they did it right.
Anyhow I think that's it.
That's emulsions
and oil and eggs.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Thank you so much.
I think we do, Victoria,
have time to take questions.
Yes?
So forgive me, super
dorky, I'm going
to repeat your question so that
those people who are watching
the video later can
hear it, otherwise
they're just going
to hear the answers.
So bear with me.
Chef in the front, did
you have a question?
So does the whisking taint
the flavor of the olive oil
the same way you spoke about
the blender shearing it.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
I mean I wish
that my hands are as powerful
as blenders, but they're not.
So no, it's because
I'm much more gentle.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: How do you
design experiments varying
ingredients?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Well, it's a lot
like any kind of experiment.
So the way you design an
experiment a lot of it
comes down to sort of intuition
and experience in the field.
So I have a good idea of
what is likely to work.
And I think that's the case in
any sort of scientific field,
the difference between
a good scientist
and a bad scientist
it comes down to a lot
to intuition and sort
of general background
knowledge of the field.
So yeah, a lot of what I decide
to test comes down to that.
And then when I'm doing
the actual experiments
it really is fifth
grade science stuff.
Isolate the variable,
have a control,
make sure you eliminate
bias as much as possible.
I do different types of
recipes and different types
of experiments.
So for ones where you can very
easily empirically measure
things like how well does
mustard emulsify versus an egg
yolk?
That one's pretty easy to do,
because it doesn't come down
to subjective taste.
A lot of experiments do end up
coming down to subjective case
and so for those often
it's just my own palate.
And I think that's one of
the differences between me
and my former employer
at Cooks Illustrated.
What we did there was we would
have big panels of people
tasting-- this one has a half
a teaspoon of lemon juice,
that one has a teaspoon of lemon
juice, which one do you prefer?
And so there you end
up with a recipe that
sort of pleases a lot
of people, but I also
think lacks personality.
So what I do is I do the
one that pleases me most
and explain to you
why it pleases me.
But if you like less
lemon juice in you thing--
the idea is that I'm
trying to arm you
with enough sort
of basic cooking
technique and
scientific knowledge
to be able to modify
the ingredient,
modify the recipe
to your own taste
and still be sure that
it's going to work.
JENNA TAYLOR: Excellent.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the
first part where
you were poaching the eggs,
was the water at a mild simmer
at the lowest--
JENNA TAYLOR: What's the
temp of the eggs or the water
when you're poaching the eggs?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
It was below a simmer.
So the main reason I like
to keep it below a simmer
is actually just a physical one.
I don't want the bubbles
coming up there and interfering
with the eggs and jostling
them around too much.
Partly I also don't
want the metal
at the bottom of the
pan to be too hot.
So ideally when I
poach eggs what I do
is I get like a
rather large pot.
I'll bring it to a boil
then I'll shut it off.
And then I'll add
the eggs to it.
So the water
temperature is probably
above 180 degrees, below 200
degrees, around that range.
JENNA TAYLOR: What temp
should the eggs themselves be?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: So,
OK, that's a good question.
So I actually like to use
fridge cold eggs for poaching.
And the main reason is
that those tight whites
and tight yolks are actually
more viscous when they're
cold from the fridge
so it makes it easier
to do that straining step.
If they come all the
way to room temperature,
especially with
slightly older eggs
there's a small
chance that doing
that step you're going
to end up breaking
the shell, the membrane
around the white
and you definitely don't
want that to happen.
So I like to use fridge
cold eggs for poaching.
JENNA TAYLOR: What got you
interested in food science?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: What's
got me interested in science?
Well, I can tell you
Don Herbert, Mr. Wizard.
If you grew up in the '80s--
JENNA TAYLOR: Yes.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: --or
in the '50s, you knew him.
He got me interested in science.
I mean I come from a
family with many scientists
so I was always
interested in science.
I got interested
in food basically
because it was the summer
after my sophomore in college
and I wanted to take a
summer off of academic work.
So I went around looking
for a job as a waiter.
And I walked into a
restaurant and they
said we don't have
any waiter positions,
but we have a prep cook who
didn't show up this morning
so as long as you know
how to hold the knife,
we'll give you a
job in the kitchen.
And I lied and I said I
know how to hold a knife
and I got a job
working in a kitchen.
And sort of faked my way
through it for several years,
but as soon as I
went into a kitchen
I was like this is
the life for me.
I loved working at restaurants.
So the way I got
interested in food science
is that I got
interested in science,
then I got interested in food.
And then I was like, oh
here are these two things
I can put together.
Worked out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Yeah, well vinaigrette
is a very good example of that.
I use one part
water-based liquid,
so that could be lemon juice,
vinegar, and then three parts
oil.
And then about maybe up to
one part in addition to that.
The liquids you
can do by volume,
but one part by weight
of additional aromatic.
So it can be garlic,
it can be shallots,
it can be some kind of
barbecue spice blend,
powdered ranch dressing
mix, whatever you want.
But yeah a vinaigrette you want
a three to one ratio of oil
to water.
That's a good one.
I would actually recommend
getting Michael Ruhlman's book.
Michael Ruhlman's one of my
idols, a great, great food
writer.
He has a book called "Ratio,"
which is specifically
about that question.
JENNA TAYLOR: How do you go
about adding vinegar to your--
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
How do you feel
about-- I think you said, how
do you feel about adding vinegar
to your poaching
liquid for eggs?
JENNA TAYLOR: Vinegar
to the poaching liquid?
How do you feel about it?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: So adding
vinegar to the poaching liquid
the idea there is that
the acidic water is
going to help the egg white
to set a little bit faster.
If I was going to poach eggs
using the traditional method,
I would add vinegar
to the water,
because you run such a big risk
of the egg white spreading out
too fast.
And it does help the egg
whites set a little bit faster.
But I also find that it
makes like a very sort
of thin kind of
almost chalky texture
along the exterior of the egg.
So using this method you don't
need to worry about the whites.
So I don't add vinegar,
because I prefer the texture
without the vinegar.
JENNA TAYLOR: What kind of a
chef's knife are you using?
Funny, you can read all
about it on Serious Eats.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Yeah,
so this chef's knife
I'm using right now is from
this company called Misen.
They just launched their
Kickstarter this morning.
They sent me this
knife about a week ago
and it's become one of
my new favorite knives.
It's high carbon steel, it's
got a polycarbonate handle,
it's like a super high
quality, really well
balanced chef's knife.
I collect knives.
I have tons of knives and this
is one of my favorite knives.
And the best part is it's
$65, which most knives are
like in a $130, $180 range.
Yeah, I would highly recommend
backing them on Kickstarter
getting this knife in March.
JENNA TAYLOR: What's your
favorite recipe in your book?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: That
didn't make it in the book?
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, that
J. KENJI LOPEZ ALT:
My favorite recipe
that didn't make it in the book.
JENNA TAYLOR: I
want to know what's
your favorite one
in the book, too.
Both.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Well, I
was in the fortunate position
where-- so originally
I was supposed
to write a 300 page book,
that's what was in my contract.
And it was supposed to
take a year to write.
It was going to come out
in like 2011 or 2012.
And then by the time 2012 rolled
around I was up to 800 pages.
And I gave it to my
editor and I thought
she was going to
kill me and then
she was like, this is good can
you give me another 800 pages.
And I was like, OK.
So I took another year
and another 800 pages.
So I was in a fortunate
position where I really
didn't have to cut anything.
So by the time
that rolled around,
that was like the end of 2013.
I was at 1,600 pages.
We were going to release
a two volume box set.
And then it turns
out that booksellers
don't want to sell a $100
book from a first time author.
So we're like, OK we can
cut it down to one book.
So we cut it down
to 1,000 pages.
So there's 600 pages worth
of recipes and things
that I really like.
Fortunately they're going
to come out in another book.
So I'm adding to
that and there's
going to be another
probably 1,000 page
book that's coming out in maybe
two years, maybe one year.
We'll see.
So the recipes
that I really liked
that got cut from this book
are going to be in that book.
But out of those recipes I
would say-- the hardest things
to cover, probably
pizza and I have a lot
of thoughts on nachos, too.
There's no nachos in this book.
JENNA TAYLOR: Don't we all?
What's your favorite
thing in the book?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
Oh, that's also hard.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's not your
children, they won't know.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: No,
it's because I forgot.
I wrote this book
like years ago.
I forgot them all.
All right, so the
first recipe you're
going to make out of
there, I would recommend
making the stove top
macaroni and cheese,
because it's literally takes
the same amount of time
as it does to open up like a
box of Kraft mac and cheese
and make it.
But it's so, so much better.
And it has that same
sort of gooey, creamy,
cheesiness that-- yeah,
it's one of my favorites
recipes in there, I'd say.
Easy, delicious,
really bad for you,
a change from the
Google food for you.
JENNA TAYLOR: We like
everything in moderation.
How could you adapt the mac and
cheese recipe for backpacking?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Well,
it's actually almost custom
made for backpacking.
So in the recipe
the only element
that I think you have
to leave out is the egg.
But it has a variety
of emulsifiers in there
that help that
sauce stay creamy.
So there's condensed
milk, which comes
in a can; perfect
for backpacking.
There's cornstarch.
And then there's a small amount
of American cheese, which
contains sodium
citrate, chemical
salts that help cheeses
melt and stay emulsified.
And then a large amount
of cheddar cheese.
So cheeses are good
for backpacking.
Everything except for the
egg, and then the pasta's dry.
So and then it all
cooks in one pot.
You cook the pasta,
you drain it,
then you throw everything
else in there, and that's it.
It's pretty easy for
backpacking, actually.
JENNA TAYLOR: Unusual tips
for egg-based desserts.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: So
desserts are not my forte.
They're not my strong suit.
There are actually no
desserts in this book.
Something that I say right
in the introduction like,
I just don't like
desserts so I don't do it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Woah, woah,
woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Because
I made a deal with myself
about five years ago that
I'm not going to do things
that I don't like anymore.
Which I think is
a deal everybody
should make with themselves.
And so I was like, all right
I'm not doing desserts.
JENNA TAYLOR: What is your
favorite Bay area restaurant
and what is the
best Google cafe?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: To be
100% honest, I don't actually
get out to eat in
the Bay area much,
because I cook so much at home.
So we live in San Mateo.
I've had some really
great meals at 31st Union.
I like Santa Ramen down there
and Dojo Ramen is pretty nice.
I had some good pizza at
Doppio Zero in Mountain View.
In San Francisco I
would say, I've always
loved Mission Chinese food.
Everybody loves that.
Pal's Take Away,
it's a sandwich shop.
It's great, it's in the
back of Tony's market.
It's not a full restaurant, it's
just a guy making sandwiches,
but they're the best.
And prune?
Not prune, no.
I had great prunes.
Francis.
Francis in the Castro and Kin
Khao, really like Kin Khao,
Thai restaurant
in the Tenderloin.
Oh and favorite cafe, I
don't remember the names.
Does anyone who
work on this one--
this is my favorite one, right?
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Kitchen
Sync for the win.
How would you do in a
cooking competition?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Kick ass.
JENNA TAYLOR: Obviously.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
I don't know.
I mean I used to
work in restaurants,
but I haven't worked
in restaurants
now for seven or eight
years, I think, maybe longer.
So I think probably
my speed has suffered.
But I think I'm a
pretty good cook.
I don't know.
That's a hard
question to answer.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Do you
miss the restaurant?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: I do.
I do.
I mean, I miss the adrenaline
and I miss the rush of service.
And I miss the camaraderie of
the kitchen is really nice.
I definitely don't
miss the hours,
I don't miss not
having holidays.
having weekends.
So some elements
I definitely miss,
but overall it's a good change
to get out of restaurants.
JENNA TAYLOR: How are home
cooks wasting their time?
They can be doing
something more efficient?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: I think
mostly it just comes down
to kitchen organization.
Particularly, I think,
people waste a lot
of time becoming cluttered.
A lot of people will
cook and they'll just
throw their dirty things as
soon as they're done with them
they'll leave them
on a cutting board.
And then you have a
nice big cutting board
and then you end up with
chopped herbs over here,
and I have a chopped
onion over here,
and some pepper skins over here.
And then you're trying
to work in like a space
this big and that's
not efficient.
So I think the number
one way to make yourself
more efficient in the kitchen
is really clean as you go,
stay organized, and also think
of yourself as a production
line.
Maybe it's not fun way
to think about cooking,
but I think it makes
it more fun in the end.
So if you're chopping up five
pounds of onions for an onion
soup, rather than working
one onion at a time
and getting it all chopped, I'll
do actually one step at a time.
So I'll take every onion
and I'll cut off the ends
and then I'll take every
onion and split them in half.
Then I'll take every
onion and peel them.
And that's way you have
less extraneous movements,
less cleaning up, and it's
much more organized and faster.
JENNA TAYLOR: How do you
feel about egg politics?
Cage-free.
Organic.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
So all right, there's
two sides to that question.
There's a flavor side and then
there's the politics side.
As far as the politics
side go, I think,
you buy it from best chickens,
the most nicely treated
chickens.
I mean, the commercial egg
industry and the dairy industry
are two of the worst industries
in the world; way, way,
worse than the meat industries.
Battery chicken hens are treated
really, really, really poorly.
So I would recommend
buying cage-free
if you have a local
farmer even better.
I would definitely do that
for political reasons.
As far as flavor reasons
go, a lot of people
say they can taste
the difference
between a cage-free egg or a
commercial egg or something
from their neighbor's yard.
Every test I've ever
seen and everything
I've ever done side
by side blind taste
test you can't tell
the difference.
They cook the same way.
They'll have differences
in appearance.
And this is a test I've done
with large crowds before.
You can show people two
pictures exactly same egg,
just photoshop the egg in one of
them a little bit more orange.
The orange egg is going
to be more appetizing.
And similarly, if
you're making scramble--
this is another
brunch tip-- if you
want your friends to have the
best tasting scrambled eggs
they've ever had
in their life, just
add a few drops of orange
food coloring to the eggs
while you're scrambling them.
And they'll be like,
oh my god these
are-- tell them you got them
from your neighbor-- they'll
be like, oh my god these are
the most flavorful eggs ever.
And really it's all
just psychosomatic.
But at the same time, it really
does taste better to them.
So I think that's a good thing.
So if can buy better eggs and
knowing the fact that those
eggs are came from happier
chickens and they're more
orange, if that actually really
makes it taste better to you
then it's like, then who cares
if in a blind taste test they
don't.
Right?
That's not what's
important, what's
important is what's in your
mouth, what's in your brain,
not what a blind
taste test shows you.
JENNA TAYLOR: Does
size matter of eggs?
Only for eggs, clearly.
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Yeah, well,
certainly in a baking recipe
it matters, because yeah
if you use different size
eggs it's going to throw off
the ratio of baking recipes.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
What's the right size?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: Most recipes
are written for large eggs.
I like to sometimes
get like jumbo eggs
if I'm going to poach them
or fry them, because it's
nice to have a nice big yolk.
My mom used to go
to a store that
would sell the double
yolked eggs for fried eggs
and she really liked those.
But in general, no.
As far as flavor and basic
chemical profile goes,
it doesn't really matter.
JENNA TAYLOR: The hardest
thing about writing a recipe.
J. KENJI LOPEZ
ALT: Foolproofing.
Yeah, it's trying to
figure out everything
that an end user might do wrong
and guarding against that.
So when you look at
recipes in this book
or on Serious Eats or
any place where's there's
really well written,
well tested recipes,
you'll find that-- I
always try and offer
like several different queues
for when something is done.
So I start with a
visual cues, so I'll
say cook it until the onions
are translucent and then
after that I also offer
like a basic timing cue.
So a poorly written
recipe would be,
cooked the onions for five
minutes over medium heat.
And that's poorly written,
because a you don't
know how much power-- this
one was cooking at 1,000,
I don't know what that means.
Is that medium?
I don't know.
And most people at
home, their gas ranges
vary so much, so you don't
know what medium heat means.
Secondly, you don't
know what kind of pan
they're going to have.
Are they going to
have an aluminum pan?
Are they going to have a
really thin nonstick pan?
Are they going to have
a stainless steel pan?
So you can specify
all those things,
but even within the range
of like stainless steel pans
there's a broad range.
So it's always much better
to give a visual cue
and say like, cook the
onions while you're stirring
until they're translucent.
This will take about
three to five minutes,
maybe, something like that.
That way you're making
sure that people are really
using their ears and
their eyes and that's
how you should be cooking.
Use a timer, use a
thermometer, but always
time things first with
your eyes, and your ears,
and your nose, and your fingers.
JENNA TAYLOR: Who eats
all of the leftovers
from your experiments?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT:
So sometimes my wife.
It depends on if it's a
recipe she likes or not.
And if it's a recipe she
likes, by the end of it
it's a recipe she
hates, because she'll
eat boiled eggs for
three weeks straight.
Sometimes it's my wife.
When I lived in New York,
I lived near my family
so I would give it away to
my mom, or my grandfather,
I would take it into the office,
my neighbors, my doorman.
Now we live in San Mateo
next to a family that
has three kids, two kids, and
so they get a lot of our food.
The dogs get a lot of food, too.
The dogs had wagyu steak for
breakfast couple weeks ago.
Lucky.
JENNA TAYLOR: What's
your favorite thing
to order when you eat out?
J. KENJI LOPEZ-ALT: It depends
what kind of restaurant.
So if it's like your
typical California cuisine--
I mean, vegetables.
I order vegetables and
fish when I eat out.
I think, if you're going to
a really high end restaurant
or even like a really
nice mid range restaurant,
I think the two best dishes
to judge a restaurant on
are actually generally
the most boring,
so I think it's a
salad and the chicken.
And those two things if
they can do it right,
those things are oftentimes
they're almost afterthoughts.
They're things like oh we have
to have a salad and a chicken.
But if they show care and
attention when they're
doing that, and perfectly
cooked chicken, I think,
could be amazingly tasty.
And a really perfectly
dressed salad
with a properly made
vinaigrette, well
balanced ingredients, that can
also be really, really tasty.
So if a restaurant does
those two things right
then I'm pretty sure that they
care about everything else.
JENNA TAYLOR: Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]